hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully you
guys have all had a chance to rewatch
the Korra finale and processes a little
bit but I asked you all to submit
questions during my review video so I
pulled a bunch for this I think the
biggest things that you guys were
talking about were crippled Korra and
the future of the series just like the
general future of Avatar so let's get to
it careful for spoilers from the
episodes if you haven't seen them yet
I'll wait just a sec ok ready here we go
question number one Kyle asks remember
how the poison used on Korra was
metallic I heard a theory that the metal
in question is mercury or the Korra
equivalent which would have left Korra
crippled and perhaps blinded hence the
wheelchair and Korra's glazed over eyes
is this true so it's totally possible
that it's mercury you know mercury
poisoning is a really serious thing and
it does cause blindness if you look at
her eyes they do look a little glazed
over I don't know that they wanted to
imply that she was blind but it's
totally possible I also saw a lot of
people asking you know about whether or
not Katara would be able to heal her
that's another possibility I do think
that she's going to recover but she will
be severely weakened I just feel like
that's gonna be a big thing in book 4
chord not being like up to a hundred
percent and still learning how to be the
avatar when she's not operating at full
steam I don't think she's gonna be in
the wheelchair forever but I do think
we'll see her in it during book 4 I'm
not expecting a huge jump in time
between the end of book 3 in the
beginning of book 4 like I think that
they'll be traveling around already like
the airbenders will be going from nation
to nation but it's not gonna be more
than like 6 months on to question number
2 this is a pretty good one LM
Overstreet asks any thoughts on why the
live-action avatar last airbender movie
did not translate well there are so many
thoughts that I'm sure all the Phantom
has about this generally and night was
like a vacuum of advice from Mike and
Bryan like Mike and Bryan tried to help
but he just did not take their advice
break has actually said that they did
have a falling out with M night at a
certain point like they were on board as
executive producers but mostly in name
only
like literally none of their advice was
taken they actually had nothing to do
with the movie the studio wanted to make
it and when they found out they offered
to direct it themselves but got turned
down I think it was because the studio
felt like they would not be able to
direct a feature that big even though
that's probably total bullcrap usually
whenever big movies get made they want
big directors attached to them
so that was why tonight was attached to
the movie but if you've ever heard the
term of race bending that's just a good
place to start when it comes to
criticism of the movie question number
three be smart asks what happened to
Ming hua and Kazan so I know it's
implied think Azam might have died
obviously I don't think that he died but
they're probably just gonna get thrown
in prison I don't think the series is
gonna revisit them too much you know
other than inside Korres head like
she'll still think about them just like
she did whenever they were trying to
kill her it would be pretty crazy though
if korra ended up having this hannibal
lecter relationship with uh Sahir like
trying to learn how to fly so that if
her body is broken you know she can
still move around question number four
WWE fan asks will book four be online
only or on Nick if it's on Nick please
promote Korra so I feel like me making
Korra videos in any form is promoting
the series just on my own I don't get
paid to do it but it will be digital
like all the places you can watch it
right now you'll also be able to watch
it whatever book four comes out it will
be on Nick comm but not on Nickelodeon
the channel question number five
fantastic ideas asks why was Korra
crying at the end oh she probably had
all the fields that all you guys had
really though I think she's just so
emotionally crushed her body's broken
and she doesn't know where she's headed
next
she's so overcome with the sheer weight
of all the things that have happened
that she just breaks down crying I mean
there are a lot of reasons people cry
like sometimes people just break down
crying and they don't understand why on
to question number six I'm sorry I
forgot who asked this but you asked can
Tenzin learn how to fly now I don't
think that really almost anybody maybe
Jinora but no one else on this series is
gonna be able to fly or at least no one
else on the series will be able to fly
that can't already do it if you remember
Zaheer said that only other one
Airbender in history obviously talking
about guru laghima was able to fly so I
don't think that all of a sudden just a
bunch of new people will be able to
learn how to do it and even if that were
true they would have to get help
learning how to do it from Zaheer and I
don't think that he's going to be
helping a lot of people anytime soon
that would be so crazy though if Korra
had like a Hannibal Lecter relationship
would sit here and went to visit him in
prison for advice question number seven
Harold asks there was a captain who was
taking care of course father who is she
and why did they put so much emphasis on
her so that character was actually
played by Zelda Williams in real life
that
Robin Williams daughter I think that
they just gave her a bigger part because
she was a notable person I think it was
them just doing something nice Robin
Williams passed away very recently and
they would have had to animate this
months and months ago so I don't think
it had anything to do with Robin
Williams passing away it's also possible
that character could be featured in book
4 but I don't think that's the case I
think this was just a one-off thing
on to question number 8 sitter million
asks how did the air vacuum work and did
Cora Platinum bend so I can answer the
second one really easily no she didn't
platinum bend she just gets a lot
physically stronger whenever she's in
the Avatar State so she just broke those
changed like with her muscles as for the
air vacuum because they had all the
extra air benders they were just pushing
more air one bender can only bend a
certain amount of air so the more
benders you have you know the more they
can work together to push more air so
essentially they were just creating like
an air funnel to suck core back onto
question number nine space gypsy asks
which spirit do you want to come back in
book four I would really like to see
Aang come back really any of the past
avatars I'm really hoping that the yank
Chen festival becomes a thing and she's
able to reconnect with her past lives
whether or not that's the case remains
to be seen but I'm also really hoping
that people get to interact with spirits
of avatar last airbender characters
again like Sokka for instance I know
it's a little fuzzy as to whether Sokka
died but I'm pretty sure that he is
confirmed dead and question number ten
last one
Kyra seventeen asks why was there no
book four of Avatar The Last Airbender
so originally avatar last airbender was
only planned as a trilogy Mike and Bryan
explained that whenever they were
creating the series they didn't know
that it was gonna be avatar
they were just developing a cartoon and
their friends said that the studio
Nickelodeon that is was looking for an
epic adventure fantasy series so that's
really how avatar was born and because
trilogies were really popular it was
planned as a trilogy as for why they
planned for books I don't think that
they originally planned Korra as for
books previously I think they planned it
you know with the first series and they
didn't know if they were gonna get
renewed so they tried to kind of close
everything up in that first season and
then Nickelodeon ordered a specific
number of new episodes so they just
broke that into three seasons thus we
get four books of Korra instead of the
avatars three but remember last
airbender had many many more
so it's per book dan Cora did someone
actually also pointed out that I think
that the finale the book 3 finale is the
hundredth episode of the avatar series
when you include the last airbender
episodes but thank you so much for so
many questions these videos always a ton
of fun to do my next bonus video is
probably gonna be based on that
interview that Mike and Brian did where
they talked a lot about the behind the
scenes course stuff so I'll try and post
that next week sometime and
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winners choko Roco and Jesse Effendi
I'll be reaching out to your channels
but you both went Amazon giftcards so
congratulations I also got a request for
Turkish subtitles which i think is
really interesting if any of you out
there in international countries don't
see the subtitles for the language that
you really want just let me know and
I'll add them it's as simple as me
checking a box Google always messes them
up so sometimes they don't make sense
but I'm happy to add any specific
subtitles that you guys want so if you
haven't seen it already I just posted my
book 4 predictions you can click here to
watch those and you can click here to
get my finale video thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you